[Music]
one of my favorite things to do with
technology is make money and by that of
course I'm talking about gambling money
the information in here is worth
millions very nice thank you very much
know what make like a tree and get out
of here
several months ago Google released a
machine learning pipeline for their
popular data warehouse bigquery in
today's video you'll learn about sequel
machine learning and cloud
infrastructure with the end goal of
building a predictive model that will
help you determine the outcome of horse
races if you're new to the channel I can
subscribe and you can find a full
walkthrough on fire ship i/o now I don't
mean to disappoint you but you probably
won't get rich betting on horses but by
the end of this video you will know how
to upload your data to big theory and
then run machine learning models against
it without needing to be a data
scientist and the model we'll build will
have predictive values but horse racing
is still very random so use this at your
own risk
first of all what is bigquery and why
would you want to use it it is a
serverless data warehouse that allows
you to store massive amounts of data and
then query that data with standard
sequel statements it provides a
centralized place to put all of your
data which might include things like
fire store Excel spreadsheets legacy
databases etc then you can make queries
against this data to use it for combined
reporting and as we'll see later in the
video for machine learning just keep in
mind it's not a production database so
you wouldn't use it in your front-end
applications for that you would use
something like fire store or a regular
sequel database to get started you just
need to have a Google cloud platform or
a firebase project then you can find
bigquery under the Big Data panel and
then I recommend pinning it to the top
just so it's easy to access on the
console now bigquery is designed to
scale the huge amounts of data and by
huge I mean petabytes of data so when
you make a query it will queue that up
as a job in the background but before we
can get to that point we need to upload
some data to bigquery there are many
different ways to do this but we're just
going to upload a CSV file to cloud
storage and then connect it as a table
to bigquery we're going to grab our
horse racing data from a site called
kaggle it's a platform that allows
companies to host their own data science
competitions and also provides a large
number of free data sets that we can use
most importantly they have this horses
for courses data set which contains
about 250,000 rows of horse racing
samples go ahead and download the horses
dot CSV file that you find on this page
now like a lot of datasets it's not
perfect and one thing I noticed is that
this data set has mismatched data types
which causes errors when it goes into
bigquery just like a regular sequel
database bigquery has a strict schema
which means we can't have mismatched
data types in our columns we could fix
this by writing some Python code or we
could just open it up in Excel and
format the number of columns as numbers
now that our data is properly formatted
the next step is to upload it to a cloud
storage bucket go to the storage tab on
GCP and then you can create a new bucket
or use an existing bucket if you have
one then we'll upload the horses CSV
file which is about a hundred and eighty
megabytes if you have a file that's less
than ten megabytes you can skip this
step and just upload it directly to
bigquery now getting back to bigquery
the first thing we'll do is click on the
add data button and then create new
dataset give your data set a name and
then you can just select the default
options here a data set is just a
collection of tables which again you can
just think of as sequel tables go ahead
and click the Create table button and
we'll connect the file that we just
uploaded to the cloud storage bucket now
normally with sequel you would have to
define your schema manually which of
course we don't have for this data set
there's at least 50 different features
or columns on that horses spreadsheet
and it would really suck if we had to go
through and define that schema manually
luckily bigquery has this thing called
schema auto-detect which will randomly
sample some of the rows and try to infer
their data type so make sure you have
that selected and we'll want to make
sure that it skips the header row and we
can do that by setting these skip header
rows to 1 after that you can click
create table and that will queue up a
job in the background to create this
table you can monitor the progress of
the job which should only take a couple
of seconds in this case and it will also
report any errors if it fails to upload
the table if everything worked you
should have a table that looks like this
where the field names matched the header
row of the CSV file you can look at the
schema and you can also preview the
actual values in the table here as well
the next thing we'll do is make an
actual sequel query against this data
set we can do this directly in the
console I keep in mind you could also do
this from the command line or with one
of the client libraries first we'll
click on create table to set up some of
the boilerplate code and we'll start the
query with a select statement which will
select specific fields from the table in
this particular data set it is the
position value that we're trying to
predict that is the result that a horse
took in a given race so 0 would be a
scratch or an on place first would be
the winner
second would be the runner-up and so on
we'll also select the horses sex and age
from this table so we can see if that
has any relationship to the position we
also want to make sure that sex is not
null of course and we'll limit it to
10,000 records just to make it easier to
work with in data studio we can go ahead
and run this query and it will run a job
in the background that will provide us
with a new table with the queried
results and there's a lot more we can
get into a sequel queries like joining
multiple tables together and things like
that but when it comes to machine
learning the first thing you generally
want to do is explore your data and
bigquery makes this really easy because
it's integrated with another service
called data studio by clicking on export
we can transfer this data to data studio
and do a visual analysis on it basically
we're taking the query that we just
created and visualizing it everything in
data studio is just point and click or
drag and drop and what I'm doing here is
creating a bar chart to see if these sex
of the horse has any relationship to its
position in the races and what we can
see here is that Colts and fillies have
a higher chance of positioning well in a
race that means this field is probably a
useful feature to include in our machine
learning model now we could train our
model directly from the bigquery console
but I want to show you a really cool
tool called data lab when I work on
machine learning problems I like to use
Python notebooks and data lab basically
gives you a Python notebook with
unlimited computing resources to set up
a data lab the first thing we'll do is
activate a shell session then run data
lab create followed by whatever name you
want to give it then it's going to ask
you to select a region then it will take
you through the steps to set up an SSH
tunnel and that's just a way for you to
access a Python notebook that's
connected to your cloud resources in the
browser it'll take a few minutes to set
up but once it's complete you can go to
the compute engine tab and you'll be
able to see the actual virtual machine
that it created keep in mind that
virtual machines accrue cost so you'll
want to shut this down after you're done
with this tutorial
once it's done go ahead and click on the
web preview button and then select
change port it runs on port 8081 so go
ahead and click change in preview and
you should be good to go now you have
this playground for all your data
analysis and processing needs and it's
already wired up with your data from
bigquery and even though we're in a
Python environment we're only going to
be writing a tiny bit of Python code the
cool thing about notebooks is that you
can run code on a cell-by-cell basis if
you're not already familiar with them I
recommend checking out some of the
examples and running the code just to
get a feel for how it works now I'm
starting from a new notebook and I first
want to make sure that
we have access to our bigquery table we
use the BQ command and call tables list
and that should list out the table that
you have in bigquery and you can also
use the help command just to list out
all of the commands available on the BQ
namespace now that we know the name of
our table let's go ahead and make a
query against it in this Python notebook
we use the BQ query command and then we
can just write a standard sequel
statement we can go ahead and click Play
then it should take a second to run and
then output the result of that query in
the notebook and we finally reached the
point where bigquery ml comes into play
we're going to write a special sequel
statement that makes a query while at
the same time creating a machine
learning model based on that data we use
the create or replace model statement
and then give it a name of ML model and
it can live in the same data set as our
horses table from here we can pass in a
variety of different options and first
we'll set the model type to logistic
regression in machine learning this is a
classification problem because we're
trying to predict a specific label which
is either first place second place third
and so on the other option is linear
regression which you would use if you
have a continuous value for example the
measurement of length which could have
any infinite number of values depending
on how precise you go and confusingly
because we have a classification problem
we use the logistic regression model
type the next thing we need to do is
tell it what our input label is or in
other words the thing we're trying to
predict which is the position field once
we have the options to find we can just
make a query to our table using select
and from and bigquery will automatically
do all of the machine learning stuff
under the hood like separate your data
into a training and validation set it
will choose the hyper parameters for the
algorithm and it will run multiple
training iterations based on what it
thinks is best
that'll take a minute and then if we go
back to the bigquery console you can see
that we now have our machine learning
model in our data set the next thing we
need to do is determine if our machine
learning model is any good we'll run
another query this time we'll select all
the fields from the model and then we'll
run ml dot evaluate and we'll point it
to the ml model in our data set then
from inside here we can make a query to
the actual horses data and evaluate it
based on that model this is going to
print out a variety of different metrics
but the one we're concerned about is log
loss that's the value that we're trying
to minimize you can also keep an eye on
the area under the curve it's currently
at 0.5 which means our model is
completely random or in other words
completely worthless how do we make this
model better well
case we're only using these sex in the
age of the horse to determine the
outcome there's a lot more data in this
data set so let's go ahead and feed that
into the machine learning model to see
if we get better results so I'm
selecting a bunch of other fields like
the handicap weight penalty barrier and
stuff like that if we have high-quality
data then these fields should increase
the predictive value of the model when
we retrain and re-evaluate the model you
can see the log loss now decreases to
zero point two nine and the area under
the curve increases to zero point seven
now we have a model that we should be
able to take to the racetrack to make an
unlimited amount of money now we can
make predictions on new data by using
the ML predict statement you would use
this one by creating a new table with
some new data that you acquired at the
race track using a similar schema you
would feed it into this machine learning
model and it would give you predictions
on that new data in this example here
I'm just randomly sampling ten items
from our existing data set and you can
see the result of that query is a
prediction for the position of the horse
in that race I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you
want access to even more content
consider becoming a pro member at fire
ship IO thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon all you got to do is
bid on the winner
[Music]